WORD WITHOUT USING IT IN OUR
REPORTING.
>> IT WAS SAID WITHOUT THINKING,
PAINTING AN ENTIRE RACE WITH A
SINGLE WORD.
BUT IT WASN'T ALWAYS A SLUR.
ORIGINALLY THE LATIN N-I-G-E-R
JUST MEANT BLACK.
BUT AT THE DAWN OF AMERICA, IT
BECAME N-E-G-A-R.
>> WHAT'S YOUR NAME?
>> KUNTAR.
MY NAME IS TOBY.
>> AND WITH SLAVERY, THE WORD
WAS CONTORTED INTO ITS CURRENT
DARK, DEGRADING HATEFUL INSULT
FOR AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> WE ARE THE KLU KLUX KLAN.
LOOK OUT, THE KLAN IS GETTING
BIGGER.
>> IT'S APPEARED IN EVERYTHING
FROM UGLY PROPAGANDA TO CARTOONS
TO NURSERY RHYMES.
IT DIDN'T ALWAYS END IN "CATCH A
TIGER BY THE TOE."
IT WAS TOSSED ABOUT CASUALLY IN
MOVIES WELL INTO THE 20th
CENTURY.
PART OF THE WAY OF LIFE.
BUT ALSO, SOMETIMES TO RAISE
CONSCIOUSNESS.
AND IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS ERA, THE
STIGMA CAME TO A HEAD.
AUTHOR JAMES BALDWIN IN THE
DOCUMENTARY "TAKE THIS HAMMER."
>> WE HAVE INVENTED THE NIGGER,
I DIDN'T INVENT IT, WHITE PEOPLE
INVENTED IT.
>> A NEW WILLINGNESS TO EXPLORE
THE IMPACT OF THE WORD.
>> ISN'T IT A LOVELY MORNING?
>> UP YOURS.
>> IF YOU TWO STARTED GOING --
HE'D BE CALLING YOU --
>> DON'T SAY IT.
>> IT HARDLY DISAPPEARED IN THE
1980s AND '90s.
SOME BLACK PEOPLE DID, A LOT.
>> THERE'S BLACK PEOPLE AND --
>> AS A SOCIETY, WE'VE TRIED TO
IGNORE IT, BAN IT, LITERALLY
BURY IT.
THE NAACP HELD THIS SYMBOLIC
FUNERAL FOR THE "N" WORD.
AND WE'VE PERHAPS ADDED MORE
GRAVITY TO THE WORD JUST BY
REFUSING TO SAY IT.
>> WHENEVER A WHITE LADY ON CNN
WITH NICE HAIR